ce matin-là en cuisine le chef amadou
diallo donne des indications assez connu
et ça ça va commencer notre garniture
pour le poulet c'est comme lui il vient
de les rencontrer tous trois participé
au concours silver fourchette pour cette
épreuve de qualification cinq équipes
constituées d'un chef cuisinier d'ehpad
l'involontaire gastronomes et d'un élève
du lycée hôtelier ou trois heures pour
sortir un plat et un dessert
les équipes ont été tirés au sort non
c'était mon rêve de venir montrer une
autre image de la deûle à nous de la
cuisine dans les ehpad
au menu de notre équipe numéro 4
escalopes de poulet farci et sa pomme de
terre surprise pour le plat joie mettre
les petits pois dans ce saladier pour
pouvoir après les mixer pour pouvoir les
mettre dans la pomme de terre surprise
et rose feuilleté aux pommes et sous
caramel laitier en dessert c'est la
mission des militants des prêts non
professionnel de cuisine mais
volontaires pour représenter son
établissement mais résidents vont venir
cet après-midi représenté aussi
l'établissement ils ont créé leurs
banderoles l'après-midi les neuf
établissements représentés ont fait le
déplacement pour venir encourager leurs
chefs ou volontaire gastronomie
[Musique]
après dégustation le jury rend son
verdict amadou diallo et son équipe sont
arrivés deuxièmes ils sont qualifiés
pour la finale du 11 février
très bonne expérience en plus sont fait
profiter nos résidents et puis ça donne
une image de nos établissements qui est
voilà qui est assez forte quand même
auprès d'eux les personnes âgées et puis
la gastronomie les eaux ces deux
concours ces deux d'ouvrir en fait des
ehpad sur sur le territoire de montrer
qu'ils sont des lieux de vie qui qui
s'engage pour le bien manger pour bien
vieillir
cette édition du concours silver
fourchette est une première dans le
département des yvelines
quatorze établissements étaient inscrits